[Music]
and let me run my business news let me
rum up business Oh
sub me too by the great outdoors it is
great I want to go camping with you guys
going camping or actually not really
camping in Cabul I'm gonna go to Utah
like in a month or so he chose me when I
say candy I'm talking about like setting
up a tent yeah a back door Ryan hates
that [ __ ] yeah I think it's just a lot
of work I do enjoy camping some parts of
camping but as a whole it's it's tired
the backpack backpack I have a backpack
oh I need a backpacking bag we'll die
well one day trip
well store owners call cops after
teachers act like bouncers stopping kids
from buying their food what hey
so they like grabbing kids like judo
Jimmy you're done put the skittles back
so if you look over here these teachers
in high vis oh that's very police ass
pretty much a highlighter vests in
Bristol in this area of Bristol these
kids basically during their lunch time
I'll come out and I don't know if you
guys had in high school you guys about
to go off-campus senior privileges at a
locked campus all the time so apparently
these teachers are going into the stores
and telling students to leave and
threatening with detentions and these
store owners are basically complaining
saying I'm losing business like that
yeah why the teachers saying that to
leave so in the school's defense they're
saying that these children only allowed
30 minutes off campus and they're going
over are they getting in trouble anyways
from coming to class late after lunch I
don't know yeah I mean that's why they
did I guess that's their enforcement
though yeah 2011 Michael Gove I guess a
political party approved something that
allowed the teachers to have this kind
of rule and over the children in certain
circumstances outside the school gates
okay so I guess this was one of the
circumstances that they approved because
these kids are being late and and I
guess some parents were complaining
about unhealthy food
I surprised my teenagers of buying chips
and soda there in London oh my god like
you [ __ ] met children like in there
also your [ __ ] kids like you [ __ ]
tell them sayings like what's your idea
of unhealthy food cuz these guys like
they do one of them is just a
convenience store right yeah no it's not
like he doesn't only sell chips and
stuff like that it's like you know he's
saying that you should be teaching your
kids what's absolutely yeah or no can't
they sue for the teachers getting more
the business apparently not because of
this because they have a because there's
a lot of a 2011 ruling that they can
they're allowed to walk into these steps
but store owners are saying these guys
are straight up standing in the entrance
of their stores yeah literally
physically banning schedule allowed to
have people go in there know that how I
feel about that is like it cuz it's a
business owner I this is my business
this is my property right and then you
can't just like [ __ ] I don't like
anything about it I'm like y'all isn't
that punishment for coming late to class
that you're already coming late to class
like that thing that already happened so
like why do you need extra enforcement
where you're like no no no you can't go
over here knowing that but you're you're
you're trying to hit it in the middle as
opposed to being like all right you come
consistently late so you lose your
off-campus privileges and we're at the
gate of the school
yeah our just failed these kids or
whatever it's just like I don't know
like we had yeah we have like
consequences when we got back into
school or whatever and all that stuff
taking outside is taking place outside
of school like that's not like obviously
I guess the idea is like oh these kids
don't care about their grades so even if
I fail them though then look they don't
care the parent stop child handoff your
responsibilities to other people like if
your kid doesn't care about school your
kids not doing whatever like don't feel
like you should be able to go out there
and yell at them for me yeah what like
what play definitely a big passing of
the buck than that forcing them not to
go into the store as opposed to just
being in the store be like hey kid it's
time to go back now
you what do you think they do like
physically block them and the kids are
like
it's like they're a foosball character
claiming that they're just staying right
there like so there's more pictures of
like this you can see that these random
just like neon green people are just
patrolling dozens you rush past them
they're just patrolling this corner with
this store so these are the stores that
are complaining Chile Bella's and this
Tuscan News convenience store and it's
just this this little corner where we're
from 2:45 to 3:15 teachers are out there
just like 2:45 3:15 there's a class well
I mean I don't know this is the tenth
different that's not America okay so
they might have different hours and
stuff ya know
oh just kidding so I lied so I read it
wrong Wow
this happened or is after school and
it's allottee to it oh yeah that's bad
this rule is actually these 30 minutes
after school these kids are not allowed
to use these stores everything for that
yeah because they want to make sure they
get home in a timely manner before like
this that's none of your [ __ ]
business
no I'm gonna wait 30 minutes for you to
book it my candy also every parent like
has different rules if their parents
like yeah I'm not gonna be home yet you
should go out and like eat somewhere
because I can't provide dinner then
they're like I'm starving because the
teacher won't let me go through this
restaurant or whatever school manager
said that it's not just these stores and
these store owners or homie likes kind
of make a big scene they're saying they
do the whole they parade though all the
shops like throughout the area children
are just not allowed into any store
before I don't know I just there's no
mention if my crime increased or
something like that they just mentioned
that I would just be hella mad that
they're trying to control me outside of
the time that I'm spending at school cuz
like I was kind of like I was just a
teeny bit most understanding like if it
was during school hours or something
we'd never yeah this is like 30 minutes
after school not [ __ ] that you let me go
I'm [ __ ] I can you know go whatever
and then anything else that's all my
[ __ ] parents like that's what you
have when you have a kid you have to
take responsibility for your [ __ ] kid
like I already hated some of the dumb
rules where they enforce while we're in
school like I remember it was like
lunchtime you can't take out your phone
I'm like why not like is this gonna
impact my learning experience that I
can't focus on whatever that's going on
during
that's cuz the adults aren't having fun
you can't have fun either these store
orders even saying to the point like
these neon like these jackets are
deterring other yeah they're like what's
going on here and it's like someone died
is it exactly does look like British
police officers to me that's true they
do Horner's is just they've had enough
where they've spent over 20 days of this
and they're just like yo man this is
like this is this one of the guys saying
he's literally losing hundreds of pounds
a day I can't believe it yeah you should
go over to the school and Baughman for
community to school Oh a shame do the
reverse no take the candy like throw it
over the school oh my god sets up
straight like a dealing Network the kids
have to do like the handshake pass
he's like do you pick up good do you
pick up that's how I'm rising like an
you know like those drug tunnels and
like from like Mexico to the US or
whatever they're like underneath like
tunnels underneath the school he's like
dealing out and they're like the
bathroom or something like that yeah I
mean what does school get in trouble of
all the kids aren't home like 30 minutes
after they like it's not but again like
work we have like our own school system
right maybe there's this different where
they do have this policy like I don't
know they had to like vote this I mean
they said this policy's been up since
2011 so but they're only enforcing it
now yeah I don't know there's not much
information in this article outside it's
a general policy and then you can in
like that the school can choose what to
do with it so finally now they're like
you know we could use this to do this
this says only certain circumstances
that this ruling can be exercised and
that's that gray area though you people
take a lot of real fun with they're just
like well well-being of children a
well-being of children means this or
whatever and then you can go and do what
you want with the you know loose kind of
definition of whatever it is but then
hopefully the backlash after this it's
like it's gonna make it stop because
that's dumbest shade hope so you'd hope
so but are these teachers getting paid
more you
no I've kind of annoyed actually if I
had to stay 30 minutes after school and
like block you know [ __ ] thing I'll
be like Jesus Christ I also don't know
how education other schools work if the
teachers are like as underpaid as ours
are right they're like I still feel like
if my day ends at like 5:00 and then you
told me that I needed to tack on another
30 minutes to go like I don't know
wrangle people at the end of the day
doesn't have you know of it's like an
hour clock and clock out and there's
actually lasted like a blank amount of
time on campus and they're like you
could be on campus or you could enforce
over there still that's still another
responsibility that I have to do and I'm
kind of annoyed if you mean like why do
I gotta like again why do I have to
police these parents kids like the [ __ ]
like it's not my [ __ ] job dude like
we have fans their fans in Bristol
specifically caught them school cut them
school indeed imagine we have like Oh
like we have a whole chunk of the
comment section that they stand there
ones who's like shopping like yeah but
these teachers yeah that'd be great yeah
are the owners gonna do a petition or
something this sounds like a very
emotional angry reaction like this guy's
first camp he literally says I'd taken
the children's money and the food was
actually almost ready and then he just
had enough and started yelling at the
teacher almost finish cooking the food
and this teachers in here telling them
to get out and not get their food and
you're gonna get detention before you
get out to the pointers like gave it to
them yeah you guys have dumb school like
rules we had high middle school had
something like that to when I thought
about it um we had an ice cream guy that
would park in front of the school and
then all the kids would go after school
there get like ice cream they get tech
backs into it and then they told me you
can't do that anymore so what he did you
just went to the next street over and
then we all would think same thing yeah
yeah yeah my ice cube bio was great he
told me BB guns and stuff what you keep
going back to the BB gun sorry it's
crazy
yeah the [ __ ] ice cream truck driver
armed entire day the donut shot up for
me they sold cigarettes on kids like
actual cigarettes right it's not like
the gum full packs of cigarettes your
children yeah
we refuse I would go up there just
getting my got so bad yeah what's up
there like I'm stuck there over there to
get my methamphetamine the dude is like
selling cigarettes and that's where I
drew the line yeah the article came out
three hours ago that this they're ending
this patrol thing nice good your wallet
fixed it
[Music]